James, Paul-- congratulations.
You've made it to the third
round of this competition,
which means you're
both one step closer
to the title of "Forged
in Fire" champion
and a check for $10,000.
When you came here, you used
our forge to create push knives.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate an iconic
weapon from history.
And that weapon
is the Katzbalger.
Introduced during
the Renaissance
in the late 15th
century, the Katzbalger
became the main sidearm
for European soldiers
known as Landsknechts.
A dominant military
force, these soldiers
defended the Holy Roman
Empire in times of unrest.
Designed for close
hand-to-hand combat,
the Katzbalger was often
shorter than other broad swords,
but quick and
efficient in action.
Soldiers wielded these
weapons in deadly ambushes,
using devious tactics to lure
the enemy into fatal attacks.
Its sturdy build and
broad, sharp blade
made it a powerful chopper,
while its signature
S-shaped guard was
instrumental in defense.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
Good luck, man.
It's day one in the
challenge and we're in Moose
Pass at the family forge.
I'm excited to get to work.
OK, the fire is lit.
Hopefully we get the
blade forged out today,
the tang and the fullers--
hey, that's our blade--
and get a good start on the day.
OK, here we go.
We're going to start
making a blade.
A piece of steel is
too wide this way.
It's three and a
half inches this way,
and it can't be over two.
So I gotta bring it this way.
If I press-- move too much metal
at once, this will fold over.
It's called a taco.
And there'll be a bad
spot in your steel.
Small bites, no tacos--
we don't like tacos.
I'm probably a little
behind schedule
right now, where I wanted to be.
I was hoping to get a little
farther with the blade.
And this really
bites me in the butt.
Imagine, it's going to turn
into something straight--
maybe.
JAMES: It feels good to be home.
Best-case scenario for day
one, get the blade forged up.
Worst-case scenario
is the shop explodes
and we all die horribly.
My biggest concern
is the fuller.
I've never put one in a blade.
First thing I'm trying
is the guillotine fuller.
It could work well, but
it's muscle powered.
That didn't work.
Guillotine is not working
nearly as much as it needs to.
I have to stop and figure
something else try.
Plan B, I need to use
a set of spring fullers
under my power hammer.
Her name is Gunhilda,
which means battle maiden.
That's good.
I've got my fuller.
It actually looks pretty decent.
Feeling pretty sweaty right now.
PAUL: Today is day
three of the challenge.
I'm a little behind
where I wanted to be.
But hopefully we can catch up.
No.
[bleep] damn.
Whoo.
You start moving too fast,
you just build problems.
Today I'm going to put
our hand guard on there.
Aw, I don't know this
is a saveable billet.
Oh no.
I'm having a few obstacles.
[bleep]
A handguard got overpressed
and it got too thin.
[bleep] damn it.
So that means I start over.
It's tough when
you have a failure
like I had on the handguard.
It cost me four hours.
It set us behind a bunch.
[bleep] done.
Agh.
Ready to go.
To be successful
today, I definitely
need to be through
with the heat treatment
and on to the rest
of the process.
The deadline looms ever closer.
But I'm not worried
about it, unless I
have something major screw up.
Ugh, there's a big
old nasty warp in it.
[bleep]
PAUL: It's morning of day five.
And today, we've got
a lot of work to do.
We're going to finish
off our handguard,
and then a lot of grinding.
I'll put this down
here like this.
Then I'll wrap this around here.
There we go.
It's going to look
something like that.
You know, I'm really feeling
the time crunch right now.
And I still have
to sharpen my edge.
See if I can get an edge on it.
Day five was rough.
I'm done.
JAMES: I'm feeling fairly
comfortable about the condition
of the blade.
I did a second heat treat
to get the warp out.
Now I'm going to get
the handle assembled.
I've got to get the grip shaped.
I don't have time to waste.
That actually feels
pretty decent.
I don't want to send this
sword to the competition
without thoroughly testing it.
Just a little off the top.
Tastes like victory.
Gentlemen, this is
the strength test--
a smith's nightmare.
So what we'll do is
we'll take your blades.
We'll lock them into
our vise over here
and fire one round
from this pistol.
Now, if your blade's strong, it
should just split that bullet.
If not, we could
have a blade shatter.
James, you're up first.
You ready?
Ready.
OK-- 3, 2, 1, fire.
[gun firing]
JAMES: The blade
is still intact.
I can't see any damage.
So we're good to this point.
You can actually see
where it left a little bit
of that bullet on your blade.
There's the tiniest deformation.
Other than that,
everything's still together.
Good job.
Nicely done.
All right, Paul.
It's your turn.
You ready?
I'm ready.
OK-- 3, 2, 1, fire.
[gun firing]
I see the bullet splits,
blade doesn't fly in half,
which was a relief.
That's almost
identical damage, Paul.
Again, you can see where the
bullet left a little scar
around along the side.
All right, good job.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, to see how
sharp your weapons are,
I will take your sword
and deliver a slash
using each side of your blade.
And I'll deliver a thrust.
James, you're up first.
You ready?
Let's do it.
All right, James, let's
talk about your sword.
Your edge is razor sharp.
On the delivery downward,
it was easily into the bag
and slashed into it.
Your tip, not coming
to an exact point,
but because of
that edge geometry,
was easy enough to
thrust into this bag.
And your blade will cut.
Good job.
Thanks.
Paul, you're up next.
You ready?
- I'm ready.
- Let's do this.
All right, Paul, on
the cuts over here,
it starts to lacerate,
but not deeply
enough to go into the bag.
The edge geometry you
have of your tip over here
isn't as sharp as I
thought it would be.
This did not penetrate
the bag at all.
When you flipped it over, same
thing also with the other edge.
It did lacerate,
but not as deep.
Overall, your blade
will still cut--
not as deeply.
Good deal.
Next up is the kill test.
The Katzbalger is a weapon that
was used in history to kill.
I will take your sword and
I'll deliver lethal blows
on this big carcass.
James, you're up first.
You ready?
Let's do it.
Let's do this.
All right, James, let's
talk about your blade.
This section right here, it
nicely sliced into the carcass.
It chopped through the
spine into some bone.
And overall, your
blade will kill.
Thank you.
Good job.
Paul, you ready?
I'm ready.
Nope.
Well, Paul, unfortunately,
your edge over here, some areas
are rolled.
And it hit the mark.
But it did not lacerate
or cut into the pig.
So, unfortunately, your
blade will not kill.
No edge at all.
Gentlemen, I
know you've worked
very hard on your blades.
But in this arena, there can
only be one "Forged in Fire"
champion.
And that champion is James.
Congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Thank you.
Paul, unfortunately, your
blade did not make the cut.
Paul, please,
surrender your weapon.
PAUL: I absolutely agree
with the judges' decision.
- Paul, thanks so much.
- Thanks.
Appreciate you guys.
I mean, I just ran out of time.
There was nothing else.
Congratulations, man.
Thank you.
His blade performed the
way it was supposed to.
And mine performed like a spoon.
I may not be the "Forged
in Fire" champion,
but ladies, I'm single
and ready to mingle.
Call me.
Love to dance.
James, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion
and will be leaving here
with a check for $10,000.
Good job.
Thank you.
I'm the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
I will never win
points for prettiness,
but the tests here or
on the battlefield,
it's not the pretty
weapon that wins.
Good job.
I'm very lucky to be
able to make a living
creating something useful.
And I will use my winnings
to make more blades.
[theme music]